i'm a lot nerdy for the record
carrie underwood mega country superstar
and self-proclaimed nerd dropping by
apple music's today's country it's all
about carrie's new single ghost story
it's enough of hopefully what people
like about me there's some drama you
know it's a cinematic song it's a great
story song it's kind of this
little revenge kind of song did somebody
say
revenge
we like the sound of revenge from carrie
and when it comes to the singer's new
album expect some fun it's a very like
singer sing sing into your hairbrush you
know in your in your house in your room
kind of album we all know and love
carrie the singer but she's a wife and a
mom first and according to carrie
there's definitely a competitive spirit
between her and her husband mike fisher
who of course is a former nhl player we
kind of can't play like board games i
got in trouble once playing board games
with some friends i'm not an athlete but
i feel like i do have kind of a lot of
that mindset which it's just that drive
to get better and to push yourself
sharing two boys together carrie
definitely has a relatable mom moment we
can all appreciate i mean last night i
carried my seven-year-old up the stairs
to bed and i'm like i don't know how
much longer i won't be able to do this
but i'm gonna do it as long as i can